so I did the only q7 is shed a whopping
325 kilogram since our contest Irvine
hall Dyson hova and we're going to find
out how it was done and what advantages
it has also new with the q7 are the
engines the exterior and above all the
interior in and all the q7 is 5 meters 5
centimeters long few other cars feel as
big that's noticeable in the interior
with a multi-function speedometer but
with this new generation audi wants to
make the heavyweight handle like a
bantamweight more like an agile sports
car than a big off-road vehicle
Domna goo is not Audi technical project
manager Stefan [ __ ] says the body
has lost 70 kilos and the doors another
30 kilos the outer shell is now aluminum
but the company didn't stop there it
went through the whole car looking for
ways to shave off extra kilos the seats
now way 18 kilos less one kilo has been
saved in the brake pedal and four in the
luggage compartment floor add it all up
and the audi q7 waste three hundred
twenty-five kilos less than before
that's the equivalent of four big men
the new q7 s exterior is angular and
modern it was a challenge for the
engineers to give the broad-based
aluminium outer shell precise design
edges optically the car seems flattered
though it is almost as high as its
predecessor and it has shaved a good
three centimeters off its length
the suspension has been substantially
altered too often toyota car tester says
the q7 is still more than 5 meters long
and weighs about 2 tons but at maneuvers
like a much smaller vehicle low weight
helps but so does all-wheel steering
which reduces the q7 s turning radius by
a meter that pays off when parallel
parking in town as well as on mountain
serpentines here's how all-wheel
steering works if you're driving slower
than 50 kilometers an hour the rear
wheels point up to 5 degrees in the
opposite direction from the front wheels
that makes for tighter turns and less
shutting back and forth
team I Tony Stefan join Amon says the
new Q sevens powerful turbocharged
direct injection engines have reduced
fuel consumption to 5.7 liters per 100
kilometers or twenty-eight percent less
in summer villa life our test car is
equipped with a 3.0 liter turbo fuel
stratified injection engine the diesel
version sells more but the tfsi is
attractive for its high torque and
decent fuel consumption of seven point
seven liters per 100 kilometers on the
new European driving norm
the q7 is roomy agile and efficient even
the starting price just under sixty one
thousand euros in Germany gets you an
interior with the out a good workmanship
the digital instrument panel puts all
the necessary information in the drivers
field of vision you can rest your hand
on the gearshift when operating the
touchpad
mezlan final says Audi has sold more
than 530,000 q7 s over the past 10 years
now it's lighter more agile and more
efficient with a luxurious interior
state-of-the-art assistant systems and a
range of good engines but I hope thinks
Audi could have been more daring with
the exterior